Drake and Pusha T are causing major
waves in hip-hop right now and after
Pusha took some serious shots and his
dis record story of added on it's
getting kind of messy and you know we
got to cut the heads off these snakes
right the rapper took some low blows at
Drake's producer 40 who's suffering from
multiple sclerosis over yo 40 hunched
over like a bee how much time you got
we also found out that apparently Drake
has a secret child with an adult film
star you are hiding a child that that
boy come home deadbeat love that baby
respect that girl forget she's a porn
star let her be your world yeah
the rapper dug even deeper into Drake's
past and found a photo of him in
blackface and because he's Pusha T he
used the photo as his cover art for the
diss track now Drake released a
statement on Instagram saying that the
blackface photo was quote a project that
was about young black actors struggling
to get roles being stereotyped and
typecasted still messy Drake push of t
even claimed on Twitter that Drake was
offering $100,000 to anyone with dirt on
Pusha despite recent events this beef is
not fresh the two artists have been
going at it for over a decade and if
history is doomed to repeat itself Drake
and his labels tendency for
comparatively weaker hits will put him
and the Young Money cash money crew at
the bottom here's how it all began the
clash originated as a label family feud
Pusha T was part of a duo group called
clips with his brother no malice clips
and Drake's future label owner Birdman
cross passed creatively for the first
time in 2002 with the hit song what
happened to that boy
the song was produced in part by furrow
who was signed to the same label as
clips we'll get to why that matters in a
little bit
in 2006 little Wayne another Birdman
labelmate grace the cover of vibe
magazine wearing a sweatshirt from the
popular street where a line
babe babe was for the most part made
famous by clips and Poirot in fact bass
designer nigo is actually the same
designer behind Pharrell's personal
clothing line billionaire boys club
so clips in Ferrell didn't like that
they also weren't for Wayne rapping
about cocaine since the clips duo was
known for being quote coke rappers mean
let's just say the clips Pharrell camp
was not here for Wayne and they called
him out on their song mister me too one
a noted Tom Bennett klappas spicy style
from the shoe to the watching the lines
were a little vague but they were
effective enough and getting people
talking Wayne was asked about the song
in an interview with complex his
response was basically a big middle
finger two clips and Perot saying that
they needed to do what happened to that
boy with Birdman for them to get popular
and Terrell was essentially a weird
nobody the clips clap back the following
year in an interview with laced magazine
stating that Birdman's burst in what
happened to that boy was actually
written by fellow Cash Money artist
Gilley the kid Gilley had a fallout with
Wayne and you can actually see him in a
brief cameo in the video in 2008
clips re-enters the studio for yet
another job in the REO intro where he
pokes fun at Wayne and Bergman's
father-son like relationship
often that would mean I'd have to kill
baby like a [ __ ] Birdman was known
as baby at the time this was a direct
and effective hit little Wayne went to
jail in 2010 on weapon possession
charges and served eight months his time
away kind of cool things down
Pusha actually said the beef was
finished in a 2011 interview with
complex the good vibes didn't last long
Canadian actor and rapper Aubrey Graham
was signed to Cash Money in 2009 under
the stage name Drake just three years
after Wayne's vibe cover controversy he
previously had made a name for himself
with his successful mixtapes Drake was
also a documented clips fan when I was
looking for like autograph stuff from
clips cuz I was like a really really big
clips $200 for eclipses autograph
microphone he was in deep now being part
of Wayne's camp Drake rekindled the thug
controversy with the song dreams money
can buy on his 2011 sophomore album take
care why make it so hard to be friendly
when I know part of his MV and I feel
like lately I went from top 5 the
remaining 5 my favorite rapper see the
loss - that ain't a laugh the shot was
extremely vague and could have been a
job at another artist but it was enough
for a direct counter shot from pushes he
and his songs don't f with me
push your raps over the dreams money can
buy instrumentals puts way up on your
hope still gets a bunch better chance
with the snow
see rappers only sophomores acting like
a boss lords now pusher had said in an
interview with HipHopDX that don't have
with me wasn't meant for anyone in
particular and that he sample Drake out
of admiration of what he did on the
track in an interview with Funkmaster
Flex a month later Drake at first said
there was no real problems with him and
Pasha but he also said that if the song
was directed at Drake pushes should
quote just make it a little more direct
next time pusher took his advice with
yet another swing on his song Exodus in
2012 he signed the one that signed with
nothing the son the three now that's bad
luck this was not subliminal it was a
full-blown attack on the YMCMB cam
Dwayne Hopson and responds with the
tweet this tweet is actually a line that
comes from his response ghoulish media
outlets and hip-hop fans were pretty
underwhelmed with the track the diss
tracks after ghoulish started getting
stronger Drake now fully backs his label
and comes after anyone that tries to
take a swing at him
so when pushed up calls Wayne a fake
blood on your favorite rapper in 2013
Drake hits back with a threat on Tuscan
leather on his 2013 album nothing was
the same I'm just as famous as my man
saw but they're still the boss don't get
sent for your hype own tracks and jump
in front of a bullet you wasn't there
for push it responded at first kind of
vaguely with this 2013 collab suicide
but then he got way more direct just a
few weeks later and mad foe with
Ludacris 2016 was a full-on attack
against Drake with Pusha T's hgtv
freestyle a direct blow against Drake's
career launching mixtape so far gone and
rumors that he had a ghostwriter it's
too far gone when the realest a real I
walk amongst the clouds
so you're still insane real with two
birds one stone
Drake successfully comes back with a
direct hit on pushin and his label mate
Kate Cuddy who had called him out on
Twitter for ghostwriting
a solid attack overall but then 2018
happens
Pusha T releases infrared which came
after a number of artists but his lines
about Drake's still using a ghostwriter
was enough for Drake to release the
duppy freestyle the same day so if you
would be with me for working with
someone else on a couple of fees what do
you really think most importantly
definitely through shots at Pusha T's
fiance Virginia Williams which caused
pushed it to go 10 times harder and add
it on and while Drake warrants and Duffy
that it'll be a cool summer it's kind of
hard to come back and push your teeth at
it on a direct hit with FBI levels of
research rap battles are more than just
wordplay and a good beat it's all about
what you can dig up on your opponent add
it on proves that push it is not afraid
to hit low and if Drake is gonna come
back he's gonna need some serious dirt
Jimmy you're falling seriously behind
you think Drake has a chance to come
back to summer let us know in the
comments below